lo que tenemos aquí son dos
visualizaciones diferentes de la
producción de un país en diferentes
puntos en el tiempo podrías reconocer
aquí a la izquierda que tenemos nuestra
curva de posibilidades de producción
para este país y es un país muy simple
que produce tenedores y o cucharas
entonces si solo produjera tenedores de
manera eficiente estaría aquí con muchos
tenedores si sólo se dedicará a producir
cucharas de manera eficiente estaría
aquí y todas las combinaciones de
tenedores y cucharas que podría producir
eficientemente utilizando todos sus
recursos es decir potencialmente bueno
eso es lo que define esta curva de
posibilidades de producción a la derecha
tenemos el pib real de este país contra
el tiempo y entonces puedes ver su pib
real como una forma de representar la
producción agregada de cucharas y
tenedores ahora sabemos que las
economías reales hacen mucho más que
solo producir todos bienes producen
millones de bienes y servicios pero
entonces necesitan
una gráfica que tuviera millones de
dimensiones o ejes lo cual es muy
difícil de entender para la mayoría de
nuestros cerebros pero lo que tenemos
aquí son tres escenarios diferentes tres
momentos diferentes para este país
ahora conectaremos los puntos entre la
visualización de la izquierda la curva
de posibilidades de producción y la
visualización de la derecha y también
vamos a pensar en otros indicadores
económicos aparte del pib real y cómo
podrían funcionar así que comencemos en
el tiempo te sub 1 justo aquí por lo que
sabemos de las curvas de posibilidades
de producción que está pasando en la
economía pausa en el vídeo y traten de
pensar en esto bien sabemos que si estás
en la curva de posibilidades de
producción estás operando a tu potencial
pero aquí tenemos una situación en la
que estamos operando más allá de nuestro
potencial esta no es una situación
sostenible esta es una situación en la
que algunas personas argumentan que la
economía se está sobrecalentando
es como si en tu vida personal
estuvieras todas las noches estudiando
para una prueba esa no es una situación
sostenible pero en 31 cuando estás
operando por encima de tu potencial eso
está asociado con un bajo desempleo y
muchos argumentarían que es un desempleo
insosteniblemente bajo y porque hay
tanta demanda de mano de obra hay tanta
utilización de otros recursos que eso
podría aumentar la presión sobre los
precios por lo tanto esto también está
asociado a una mayor inflación ahora
cuál sería el tiempo de su boom o en
esta gráfica bueno ya lo representé aquí
podría ser este punto que tenemos aquí
donde nuestro pib real está por encima
de esta línea horizontal que representa
nuestro pib potencial nuestro pib de
pleno empleo nuestra producción con
pleno empleo esto muestra que tenemos
una brecha de producción positiva así
como cuando estamos por encima o más
allá de nuestro cpp que también es una
brecha de producción positiva
ahora a veces asociamos esta brecha de
producción positiva que se está
desempeñando más allá del potencial a
una expansión más que a una recesión y
sin duda t sub 1 está sucediendo durante
una expansión una expansión es una
situación en la que el pib está
creciendo entonces esta es una expansión
y luego si pasamos del siguiente vaya al
siguiente pico aquí hay una expansión y
lo opuesto a una expansión es una
recesión así que esta es una recesión en
la que vamos de un pico a un valle y si
pasamos del siguiente pico al siguiente
valle eso también sería una recesión
entonces esta brecha de producción
positiva está sucediendo durante una
expansión pero podrías tener una
situación en la que estás justo donde
tienes una brecha de producción positiva
donde estás operando más allá de tu
potencial pero la economía ha empezado a
contraerse entonces no siempre es el
caso a pesar de que las brechas de
producción positivas se asocian con las
expansiones
siempre ocurre durante una expansión
pero de todos modos sigamos adelante en
el tiempo digamos por varias razones que
nuestra economía se ralentiza un poco y
vamos al tiempo de sub 2 ahora estamos
funcionando en el potencial
estamos en nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción entonces en
qué punto podría estar esto en esta
gráfica bueno lo tenemos representado
aquí en el tiempo de sub 2 el país está
operando exactamente en su potencial el
país está operando eficientemente de una
manera sostenible y luego vamos al
tiempo de subtes entonces en el tiempo t
sub 3 está claro que tenemos una brecha
de producción negativa y también se
puede ver aquí tenemos una brecha de
producción negativa y si piensas en los
indicadores económicos distintos del pib
real que van a hacer esta es una
situación en la que una economía está
operando por debajo del pleno empleo
donde la tasa de desempleo podría ser
elevada o es típicamente elevada cuando
se tiene esta brecha de producción
negativa
que tanto el trabajo como a menudo otros
recursos no se están utilizando en su
totalidad es posible que no haya mucha
presión sobre los precios entonces en
esta situación la inflación sería menor
y en casos extremos incluso podría tener
inflación negativa que llamaríamos
deflación ahora asociada con todas estas
ideas esta es la idea del crecimiento
económico
entonces en el lenguaje cotidiano cuando
las personas hablan de crecimiento
económico por lo general hablan de
expansiones están hablando de
situaciones en las que el pib real está
creciendo pero cuando los economistas
hablan de crecimiento económico no se
refieren a eso para un economista el
crecimiento económico es el aumento del
potencial de una economía y sabemos que
la única forma en que aumenta el
potencial de una economía es cuando de
repente se tienen más factores de
producción mejores recursos mejor
tecnología la población ha aumentado
entonces el crecimiento económico se
asociaría con la modificación del cpp
real si ves que ahora tienen más
tecnología o más personas entonces esto
empujaría el cpp y el crecimiento
económico por ejemplo si esta línea roja
que es el potencial del país aumentará
así eso sería crecimiento económico
probablemente el pib real en cualquier
momento dado tendría estos ciclos sobre
el pib potencial hasta el próximo vídeo